from brainwashed sleeper agents to a
witch coven disguised as a dance studio
these movie remakes are way better than
everyone remembers
the original 1968 sci-fi classic Planet
of the Apes was more than just an
action-packed adventure starring
Hollywood Legend Charlton Heston it was
capped off by one of the greatest twist
endings in cinema history written by the
master of surprise twists himself Rod
Serling a thoughtful and
thought-provoking film with unsubtle
layers of social commentary its Thrills
and Spills were punctuated by a powerful
anti-war message at a time when fears of
nuclear Annihilation were very real
nearly 50 years later Rupert Wyatt and
Matt Reeves would launch a well-received
reboot series starring Andy Circus
oh
but somewhere in the middle Planet of
the Apes became the subject of a 2001
remake by Tim Burton and did solid
numbers at the box office but was
quickly forgotten Burton's effort was
dragged by critics as poorly produced
action schlock with thinly written
characters and felt almost nothing like
the original though some of the
criticism was valid the film is seen
very differently if you can separate it
from the Heston original on its own
merits Burton's version isn't bad at all
it's just a very different movie
foregoing the more cerebral slow-paced
drama for fast-paced big budget action
when viewed as a blockbuster
Extravaganza one can Overlook its flaws
and enjoy it much more as a roller
coaster adventure with top-notch special
effects and impressive action sequences
in makeup one could argue the film may
have been better off as an original
story but as it stands Burton's Planet
of the Apes is a sorely underrated
remake largely forgotten by time as a
one-off between the original Apes films
and the 2010s rebooted franchise
an iconic 80s war movie the original Red
Dawn pitted a group of American fighters
against Russian soldiers set in a world
where the Soviet Union has grown its
influence the film begins with a Russian
assault of the United States but as
armies of Soviet soldiers parachute into
Colorado one group of young men and
women led by actor Patrick Swayze rise
up to fight back against their common
Invaders in 2012 fresh off of his Marvel
debut in Thor emerging Action Hero Chris
Hemsworth starred in a long delayed
remake of Red Dawn the film boasted an
equally eyebrow raising Supporting Cast
that included Jeffrey Dean Morgan Josh
Hutcherson Adrian Palicki and Josh pack
instead of the Soviets this time around
though the Invaders are russian-backed
North Korean soldiers and Hemsworth
stars as a young Marine who pulls
together friends and allies to fight
them roasted by critics for its lack of
depth many seem to completely miss the
point of this remake of Red Dawn though
the original may offer somewhat better
characters this 2012 version is
everything a fan of the genre could want
high octane action run and gun fight
scenes and a briskly paced ridiculous
War story as much as Die Hard fans of
the original will tell you it doesn't
compare if you can remove your
rose-colored Nostalgia goggles you'll
find the Remake is a silly old school
action movie worth watching
some remakes become underrated not
because the Critics whiffed on them but
because they are remakes of long
forgotten films such is the case with
the 1988 comedy Dirty Rotten Scoundrels
starring Steve Martin and Michael Kane
which received good reviews and did
reasonably well with the box office but
rarely makes anyone's list of best
remakes pretend to enjoy yourself laugh
out loud
the film was rejiggered from the premise
of a 1964 film called bedtime story that
film starred Marlon Brando and David
Nevin as womanizers and con artists who
set their eyes on the same Target a
wealthy heiress played by Shirley Jones
the 80s version directed by Frank Oz had
Martin and Kane in the same roles Kane
was scamming unsuspecting women out of
their fortunes through various High
concept long con type schemes and was
repelled by Martin's crude lowbrow
common con man tactics taking Martin's
character under his wing the two
eventually agree to team up and work on
a rich heiress named Janet played by
Glenn Headley but after some clever
twists the question becomes who's
conning who the comedic Chemistry
Between Martin and Kane was terrific in
this clever 80s comedy decades later it
still remembered as one of Martin's best
even if it rarely gets the recognition
it deserves
a spiritual sequel to George Romero's
1968 film Night of the Living Dead his
78 flick Dawn of the Dead brought
zombies back to theaters with a bit more
focus on violence and Gore a highly
influential film it set the action
within the confines of a shopping mall
with a group of survivors and a zombie
apocalypse Under Siege by the undead
often copied few could hold a candle to
its sheer audaciousness and social
commentary but more than 25 years later
writer James Gunn and director Zack
Snyder took a crack at a straight-on
remake starring Makai Pfeiffer Ving
Rhames Sarah Pali Jake Weber Ty Burrell
and Matt freuer it was faithful to the
original in terms of its overall plot
progression but with solid action and
over-the-top amounts of Gore that
displayed the talents of Gunn and Snyder
just before they broke through to become
superheroa tours it took the premise to
new places although it can be argued
that it lacked the deeper meaning that
made Romero's original so substantive
nevertheless those Looking for all-out
zombie action got exactly what they were
looking for and Snyder has never made
any apologies for his focus on spectacle
unfairly held up against Romero's
Masterpiece the 2004 version of Dawn of
the Dead was largely unloved upon its
release but over time has earned a
following today it's seen as one of
Snyder's best films with Bloody
Disgusting going as far as to call it
one of the greatest horror remakes ever
if you're simply looking for big budget
action and state-of-the-art special
effects there's a great Joel Kinnaman
Gary Oldman and Michael Keaton film from
2014 perfect for you unfortunately it
was titled RoboCop so nobody wanted
anything to do with it criticized for
missing the point of the 1987 Classic
this is one remake that seriously
suffers from unjust comparisons the
original film was directed by Paul
verhoven starred Peter Weller and
examined a nihilistic cold near future
where private Enterprise had taken over
law enforcement employing over-the-top
Gore language and violence the Remake
had well practically none of that but
what it kept was the always cool image
of a robot cop and who wouldn't want
that I'd buy that for a dollar while the
original had its tongue firmly planted
in its cheek with razor-sharp political
satire and gut bursting violence the
Remake took a different route the Crux
of the story Remains the Same with
Detroit cop Alex Murphy mortally wounded
and resurrected as a robot cop but it
has an entirely different tone and
largely drops the original's lust for
graphic violence instead the plot serves
as more incisive commentary on drone
Warfare in a more serious take on the
premise unfortunately the Remake didn't
land with audiences or critics script
leaks and costume dissection killed the
film before it even hit theaters and
inevitable comparisons with the original
finish the job the 2014's RoboCop does
what a remake should taking a
time-tested idea and trying to do
something new and different women in
this case the Remake uses sci-fi to
offer a takedown of modern military
politics and it works better than most
were willing to give it Credit
One of Hollywood's seminal political
Thrillers John frankenheimer's 1962
drama The Manchurian Candidate defined
the genre with tensions between the
United States and Russia at their
highest the film landed in theaters
smack dab in the middle of the Cuban
Missile Crisis making it all the more
timely and topical in the film a
politically connected War veteran is
unknowingly brainwashed into carrying
out an assassination of a key figure in
an upcoming presidential election
shortly afterwards the assassination of
John F Kennedy would make the film feel
even more prophetic some may have felt
that the timeliness of The Manchurian
Candidate made it an unlikely choice for
a remake but it was remade in 2004 by
director Jonathan Demi This Time
starring Denzel Washington the Remake
was released during a period of similar
unrest at heightened paranoia in the
United States following the events of 9
11. in this new version we meet Gulf War
veteran Bennett Marco whose fellow
Soldier Raymond Shaw is now running for
vice president but recent nightmares and
an odd implant found under his skin
reveal a Sinister conspiracy that may be
hiding a horrifying truth bringing the
story up to date for the 21st century
the 2004 version of The Manchurian
Candidate brings a new angle that helps
it stand out while still living up to
the ideals of the original though well
reviewed it is rarely discussed among
great modern remakes but with political
tensions on the rise at home and abroad
perhaps the time has come to yet again
remake one of the best thrillers of the
1960s
how do you remake one of the greatest
most iconic westerns of all time well
John Sturgis is the Magnificent Seven
was in fact a retelling of the Akira
Kurosawa film Seven Samurai that moved
the action from Japan to the wild west
so perhaps people shouldn't be so
skeptical then again sturgis's
Magnificent Seven is a classic for a
reason it presented Yul Brenner at his
best and made stars out of Steve McQueen
Robert Vaughn Charles Bronson and James
Coburn but Antoine fupa's remake was
less about its direction and genre
defying Innovation but instead it
boasted a diverse Dynamic cast and some
solid suspense telling the story of a
Drifter and Gunslinger hired by the
people of a small town to help defend
against the marauding villain and
bringing in six more Outlaws to help him
with the cause the plots of both the
original and the Remake are fairly
similar but smartly choosing not to
emulate the style and tone of the
Sturgis classic the Remake goes for a
western Thriller some key changes to the
story made it more of a tense character
drama with a focus on the hero's
personal scores and tragic backstories
co-starring Ethan Hawk Peter sarsgaard
Vincent D'Onofrio and Chris Pratt the
talent in front of and behind the camera
is undeniable and coupled with The
Manchurian Candidate and The Taking of
Pelham One Two Three clearly Denzel
doesn't shy away from lending his
talents to challenging remakes the newer
Magnificent Seven delivers the goods in
very different ways than the original
and taken together they would make an
excellent double feature
a cult classic of supernatural horror
1977's Suspiria was directed by Italian
filmmaker Dario Argento and was famous
for its striking visuals an overwhelming
synth score more about its look and feel
than its story it followed a young
student arriving at an Elite Dance
Academy run by a coven of other worldly
witches in the midst of a power struggle
the witches are working to resurrect an
ancient evil known as mother suspiram
the story plays out as a suspenseful
mystery as murders pile up to reveal
Supernatural Secrets the 2018 remake
starring Tilda Swinton and Dakota
Johnson is nearly the polar opposite
though it retells the story practically
beat for beat instead of a mystery the
audience now knows the school's secret
right off the bat but watch as its
newest student is recruited into their
blood cult while the original was a
strikingly colorful extravaganza the
Remake is a beautifully shot but
otherwise more grounded gritty film
focus more on character than shock value
with a strange disquieting tone that
escalates as the film progresses reviews
of 2018's Suspiria were decidedly mixed
with some critics describing it as
shocking and others bold and daring
though divisive the Remake is an
unmissable movie for anyone who loves
the art of film be warned however as
it's not for the faint of heart
[Music]